donc je m'appelle lorraine et je vais
aussi vous parler de mon terroir de
comment je le vis depuis
depuis presque cinq ans sur les marchés
vous voyez ici avec ma camionnette et
aussi sur internet comme on l'a dit
parce que pour moi les deux ne sont pas
incompatibles
j'ai trouvé aussi sur internet
l'authenticité que j'ai recherché dans
ma démarche
exemple d'un échange qui se passe sur
twitter
là il s'agit d'une d'une blogueuse
culinaire que je connais qui va
mentionné shop boys excusez moi qui va
mentionné le lien de ma boutique en
ligne à un de ses contacts via twitter
la personne va passer commande va le
faire sur son mobile m donc une capture
d'écran de cette commande
et voilà s'ensuivent là c'est la faute
au delà de la livraison de ma commande
s'en suivent comme ça un échange avait
entre ses plats il est bon moment qu'il
va passer à table et moi j'en vois que
la relation finalement elle est elle
devient assez vite naturel et même
intime pour voilà pour vous raconter
comment j'en suis arrivée là bas je vais
vous parler un petit peu de de mon
parcours
donc je suis née il ya un peu plus de 30
ans dans une famille qu'on dira que je
dirais classique qui parle peu mais qui
travaille beaucoup principalement dans
les métiers de la restauration
donc toujours chez moi on a été autour
de la table et l'alimentation est
toujours été présente
par contre les métiers de la
restauration c'est quand même un domaine
dont on a essayé de me
2 me pas de me dégoûter mais on m'a
vraiment dit voilà ce sont des métiers
prenant si tu le peux choisi plutôt
autre chose à l'époque adolescente
s'était pas voilà un problème ça ne
m'intéressait pas plus que ça donc je me
suis dirigé vers des études
universitaires de lettres où j'ai fait
une licence en littérature italienne
journalisme et histoire de l'art alors
voilà à la suite de cette licence que
j'ai obtenus en 2006 20 il s'agit d'
voilà de m'insérer dans le monde du
travail
ma première expérience un stage qui a
abouti sur un emploi pour une marque de
vêtements de sport haut de gamme
j'ai été en charge voilà de la
logistique des vents de la communication
donc j'étais
voilà dans ce bureau je gagnais
correctement ma vie je faisais ce qu'on
attendait de moi
mais un jour j'ai je lève la tête de mon
écran je regarde mais mais mais quatre
murs et je me dis waouh ça va être ça
mon quotidien pendant les dix quinze
vingt ans à venir
ça va pas le faire je tombe je rentre le
soir et je tombe sur cette photo de moi
enfant est vraiment je me dis mais où
est passée cette petite fille avec ses
rêves où sont passés les moments
précieux à la table de la cuisine le
goût des cuisses dam de ma grand-mère
chaux de fonnière où sont tous ces
moments là de bonheur parce que je fais
partie de la génération du bonheur la
génération des héros de magail bird de
madonna des bisounours et du coup cette
première confrontation au monde du
travail je me suis senti un petit peu
trahi je me suis dit mais c'est pas ça
que à quoi je m'attendais
et voilà j'étais complètement pleines de
repères enfin justement sans repère un
repère qui m'est resté comme je disais
avant bas c'est de nouveau ce goût des
bonnes choses des moments à table les
moments où on prend le temps que j'avais
envie de voilà de retrouver donc du coup
là on est on est en 2009 je suis voilà
complètement perdu mon amoureux à
l'époque indépendant comprenez bien ce
voile à cette période par laquelle je
passais et on sait dieu que si tu as
besoin de prendre un peu de temps
faisons le voilà on verra bien où ça va
nous mener en parallèle je me sentais je
vois là mon rapport à la nourriture
était un petit peu désincarnées parce
que j'avais à part les affiches de manor
avec le paysan local
pardon s'être vite avec le paysan ou
alors la marmotte qui emballe le
chocolat et cgt j'avais perdu cette
connexion finalement à ma commence
nourrit d'où viennent les choses qu'on
consomme notre lien à la terre aux
saisons parce qu'on nous propose
toujours des nouvelles façons de
consommer de s'alimenter qui vont
toujours plus vite qu'ils sont qui sont
toujours plus simple finalement
et moi ça me satisfaisait pas j'avais
vraiment envie de retrouver par moi-même
finalement ce lien ce lien à la terre
cette connexion aux saisons et de
réapprendre par moi-même en fait donc
est ce qu'on a fait on a on a pris la
route
et puis on est allé un petit peu se
promener dans les campagnes à la
rencontre des artisans tout à fait
simplement voilà on à toquer aux portes
et on a été souvent très bien accueilli
j'ai goûté à des choses j'ai découvert
des produits est vraiment tout un tout
un panel de choses auxquelles j'avais
peu accès en ville finalement là vous
avez une photo de mme et artisans il
s'agit des artisans avec lesquels je
travaille depuis plusieurs années donc
il s'agit pas d' d'un j'ai pas pris sa
sueur sur google image est vraiment je
découvrais tout ces gens tous ces beaux
métiers qui mettait à ces inconnues
apiculteurs comme on l'a dit et caetera
et vraiment je me suis dit mais moi en
ville j'ai peu accès à ça donc là on
était il ya quelques années
il doit bien y avoir un moyen de pouvoir
leur donner une immunité bilité en ville
et j'avais vraiment envie de raconter
leur histoire là on à monsieur en show
qui fabrique des fromages de brebis
j'avais vraiment envie de faire le lien
entre ces gens et le consommateur auquel
je fais partie et de raconter leur
histoire
alors internet c'est bien les réseaux
sociaux c'est super mais aussi à
l'époque ce qui pour moi était important
c'était d'aller à la rencontre des
clients des gens comme je lé fais
d'aller à la rencontre avec les artisans
finalement et donc donc c'est là que
l'idée d'une petite épicerie commencé à
naître
c'est trop tard s'être vite l'idée de
base c'était ok comme on peut l'imaginer
en magasin un local à lausanne d'ajouter
à l'époque originaire de lausanne
et tout cela finalement a entraîné une
démarche de mon côté donc pour pour
développer se développer ce projet
également pour mme pour me former aller
à la rencontre des fans de nouveau que
les artisans me m'explique davantage
quelles sont les implications de leur
métier parce que comme vous l'avez vu
c'était pas ma formation donc j'ai pris
quand même pas mal de temps pour ça
trouver un local à lausanne en étant
seul et ça c'était quand même assez
compliqué et quand j'a
à un moment donné j'ai vu une annonce
pour la vente d'une d'une camionnette à
trois roues et je suis allé voir cette
cette camionnette
je les regardais elle m'a regardé
c'était le coup de foudre et on savait
qu ensemble on allait on allait faire
quelque chose alors cette camionnette
il a fallu la halle aménagée on lui a il
a aménagé donc pour refaire instant de
marché et c'est là que de nouveaux le le
projet amène de belles de belles choses
parce que bien évidemment que que je me
suis fait aider de designers de
carrossiers et c'est pour aménager cette
camionnette et je pense que les gens ben
voilà les projets un peu fous par face à
leur parler ils sont venus m'aider avec
plaisir est là un mois plus tard en
décembre 2010 voilà il est c'est mon
premier marché je suis accueillie
on en décembre donc il fait froid mais
je suis là mon premier marché donc à
partir de ce moment là j'ai voilà j'ai
été présente sur les marchés
hebdomadaires avec la camionnette le
plus possible pour vraiment faire ma
place parce que comme vous vous en
doutez peut-être un monde qui était très
nouveau pour moi piqué aussi pas
toujours pas toujours simple donc il
s'agissait de faire ma place de montrer
que j'étais sérieuse que je ne venais
pas uniquement quand il faisait beau et
chaud donc j'ai passé des des moments au
froid et humide mais mais j'ai tenu bon
et aujourd'hui mon rôle a évolué je
reste toujours la garante finalement de
cette voie là de cette tradition appui
de ses échanges entre entre artisans et
les consommateurs je développe une gamme
de produits sous sous mon nom justement
pour relayer les je relaye les
commentaires aussi des clients j'échange
avec mes artisans et de là on créer
ensemble une gamme de produits ce qui
est important pour moi aussi c'est là la
transparence quant aux quant à
l'étiquetage donc quant à ce que
contiennent ces produits éviter quand
même le plus possible voilà les
ingrédients qui sont peu ragoûtant là
vous avez encore un exemple de produit
dès le début comme vous l'avez vu c'est
un projet assez personnel donc dès le
début tout est fait main est fait maison
on a sérigraphié des sacs des tissus et
c'est donc de nouveau
tout effet voilà tout est fait main
encore un exemple
alors aujourd'hui bas je continue à me
déplacer de marché en marché
je vais twitté ma position pour informer
par exemple mes clients ainsi que je
suis là où je suis sûr tell tale telle
foire tel événement je vais échanger sur
facebook par exemple avec avec mes
clients je vais faire une photo
instagram pour montrer qu'il fait un
temps magnifique et qu'il faut
absolument venir est toujours le plaisir
du moment le partage pour moi c'est
vraiment des choses qui sont qui sont au
coeur de ce projet là l'importance
d'avoir cette présence en ligne pour
expliquer raconté raconter les coulisses
aussi je pense que les gens sont
sensibles à ça donc
donc il ya ces différentes présent ce
que j'essaie de 2 voilà d'alimenter j'ai
proposé il ya quelques temps j'apporte
l'apéro un concept sur rui quittent le
site de crowdfunding dont on a parlé
il s'agit d'un d'un service de livraison
d' apéros donc à base de produits
artisanaux locaux qui est devenu bas
grâce à wii mais qui est entre autres
apéro vélo ça veut dire que vous
commandez votre vous commandez votre
apéro sur internet ou sur votre
téléphone portable et dans l'eure vous
avez un coursier à vélo de vélocité en
ville de lausanne qui débarque et qui
vous apporte votre apéro donc là vous
avez un exemple la boutique en ligne
donc toujours avec les fonctionnalités
bas de boutiques en ligne traditionnels
mais vous pouvez aussi venir chercher
vos produits au marché où vous pouvez
payer aussi avec carte de crédit parce
que maintenant on a des solutions aussi
mobile de paiement par cartes qui sont
vraiment super pratique donc c'est ça
que j'essaye aussi de mettre en avant
donc mâché lorraine c'est quoi vous
l'aurez compris ça reste une petite
blonde au volant de sa camionnette sur
les marchés de la région
une boutique en ligne toujours ses
services axée sur le partage que
j'essaye de développer et comment
comment je vois le futur alors pour moi
le futur bâle à vous avez c'est un peu à
tirer mais une telle faute c'est là un
exemple la future boutique en ligne qui
va être bientôt mise au point toujours
l' envie de développer cette gamme de
produits pour proposer des voies là des
produits assez unique différent et puis
cette transparence quant à l'art à la
composition
j'ai ouvert un espace à genève au sein
d'un concepteur de la gare cornavin donc
quand même l'envi de décès dans ta reese
est un tout petit peu et de pouvoir se
poser un prochain projet également dans
la vo sur le même concept mais pour
l'instant je n'en dis pas plus j'essaye
toujours de tester des nouveaux nouveaux
services par exemple à genève on va
lancer un panier gourmand sur abonnement
avec des maraîchers
qui travaillent donc uniquement à genève
et du coup on aura le panier gourmand
avec mes produits et aussi
voilà des produits des produits frais
delà de la région et donc avec toute
cette accélération avec tous finalement
cette présence des technologies comme je
l' ai dit c'est comme qui me qui me
servent bien évidemment bien sûr tout va
plus vite mais finalement je vois quand
même mon futur est sûrement le futur de
beaucoup d'entre nous très traditionnel
autour de la table de la cuisine pour
partager des des bons produits des bons
moments et voilà c'est ça qui me fait me
lever tous les matins même par moins 10
voilà merci de votre